[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de 7,8 échos le magazine consacré à
l'actualité économique de notre
territoire sans plus tarder voici le
sommaire
nous sommes dans ce moment en pleine
période de soldes des bonnes affaires
que vous pouvez faire sur l'ensemble du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
premier pôle commercial de notre
département ce secteur qui ne cesse de
se développer booster l'économie
saint-quentinoise
c'est le dossier thématique de ce numéro
et grigori gars rester vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines délégué à la
stratégie commerciale sera sur notre
plateau humaniser l'informatique c'est
ce que développe depuis deux ans une
jeune start-up yvelinoise ultra leur
solution permet à n'importe quel
utilisateur d'avoir accès à un
ordinateur et même si les malvoyants
enfin nous ferons un point sur le reste
de l'actualité économique dans les
yvelines avec notamment les bons
chiffres de l'automobile pour les
constructeurs installés dans notre
département
elle met aussi un sommet sur
l'attractivité au château de versailles
mais avant de développer tous ces titres
ouvrons ce magazine avec un chiffre 2,14
milliards d'euros c'est le chiffre
d'affaires de st quentin en yvelines
générés chaque année par le commerce
saint quentin en yvelines qui possède
sur son territoire plus de 300 mille
mètres carrés de surfaces commerciales
dont plusieurs grands centres
commerciaux
l espace saint quentin skywest à
montigny le bretonneux paris ouest à
maurepas grand plaisir à plaisir ou
encore owen les chaînes paris aux
clayes-sous-bois plusieurs autres
projets commerciaux sont également
prévues d'ici les prochaines années on
aura bien sûr l'occasion d'en reparler
avec notre invité dans quelques minutes
mais tout d'abord focus sur cette jeune
start up yvelinoise depuis deux ans ibra
a développé une solution informatique
qui permet à n'importe quel utilisateur
d'avoir accès à un ordinateur un concept
novateur au service notamment des
malvoyants reportage vous allez pouvoir
faire des messages écrits d'accord donc
si vous avez si vous vous déplacez avec
vos flèches aurait mort accompagner les
personnes déficientes visuelles pour
qu'elle puisse être autonome face à un
ordinateur c'est le défi que la start up
à guez hypra a décidé de relever
corentin voiseux et jean-philippe
mengual se sont rencontrés sur les bancs
de sciences po il décide en 2015 de
lancer le premier concept de pc a accès
universel francs compte que seulement
deux personnes sur dix parmi les
personnes déficientes visuelles
on se rend compte que moins de 50% des
personnes âgées de plus de 60 ans
disposent d'un ordinateur à la maison et
on se dit là effectivement il ya quelque
chose qui bloque assistance vocale zoom
puissant interface simplifiée
personnalisable t'arrive de cette
solution tout compris entre 1500 et 2000
euros
voilà je pour cela qu'il faut faire
entrer en jeu la personne qui passe par
l'ons au moment où elle achète elle
achète aussi la formation donc avec le
produit ont fourni la formation pour que
la personne s'approprient l'outil dans
tous les usages qu'elle souhaite et
qu'elles puissent ensuite de manière
autonome elle le plus loin possible dans
ses usages
depuis deux ans 150 personnes en france
dont plusieurs dans les yvelines possède
la solution hypra comme cette cliente à
trappes et j'ai un problème ou une
difficulté je vous appelle et on se fond
on se connecte directement sur
l'ordinateur et qu'imad à distance
objectif pour hypra dans les prochains
mois consolidée et enrichir ce concept
ouvrons à présent notre dossier
thématique consacré au commerce à saint
quentin en yvelines notre territoire
compte 2500 d'établissements commerciaux
et accueille régulièrement de nouvelles
en scène c'était le cas il ya trois mois
à skywest avec furet du nord
trois mois après quel est le bilan
réponse dans ce reportage
on a fait une petite table avec le coup
de coeur donc toutes les meilleures
lectures de l'équipe librairie depuis
trois mois les saint quentinois peuvent
découvrir l'offre culturelle proposée
par l'enseigné furet du nord
un réseau de 17 magasins répartis dans
le nord et en ile-de-france à skywest on
peut y trouver 40 mille références de
livres et 15 mille produits loisirs
chaque jour on a de nouveaux clients
donc c'est chouette de voir que une
vraie progression tous les jours et on
est très contents de nos résultats
jusqu'à présent avec
des week-ends avec beaucoup beaucoup de
familles qui viennent des vacances
scolaires qui fonctionne super bien
en plus de la littérature l'enseigne
s'est diversifié ces dernières années
avec des produits de loisirs créatifs du
multimédia de la papeterie ou encore des
jeux pour enfants une offre qui s'étend
ici sur près de 2000 m² nous sommes
venus au cinéma et on a vu cette
enseigne nouvelle donc voilà c'est une
découverte
la première impression c'est l'espace
quand on passe devant la porte laborde
l'impression que ces petits séance de
dédicaces démonstrations de jeux
ateliers de loisirs créatifs
l'enseigne mise également sur
l'événementiel pour attirer la clientèle
qu'elles soient adultes ou plus jeunes
c'est très important pour nous de faire
vivre à nos clients différentes
expériences en magasin les gens sont
très demandeurs
et là notre prochain événement c'est la
nuit harry potter pour les 20 ans de la
sortie du livre harry potter qu'on
organise tout un tas d'animations dans
le magasin a commencé par une cérémonie
de répartition avec le choixpeau pour
savoir dans quelle maison on va être
envoyée donc il ya des êtres des
ateliers qui sont pour les plus grands
mais aussi pour les plus jeunes
son communiqué de chiffres le magasin
furet du nord à skywest confie avoir
atteint ses objectifs
après trois mois d'ouverture depuis le
10 janvier vous avez peut-être eu
l'occasion de faire de bonnes affaires
grâce aux soldes d'hiver nous avons
voulu savoir comment se dérouler cette
période dans un centre commercial
outlet et il en existe un à saint
quentin en yvelines one nation paris aux
clayes-sous-bois des remises garantit
toute l'année c'est la promesse de one
nation paris ce centre outlet réuni 400
grandes marques sur vingt-quatre mille
mètres carrés du prêt-à-porter et des
chaussures de la lingerie ou encore des
vêtements sportifs vous avez les
produits collection l'année dernière qui
arrive et c'est avec un minimum de 30%
en moins par rapport aux prix boutique
ça peut aller beaucoup plus bas
le minimum et le 30 % donc voilà et
après si
nous sommes comme actuellement parc de
sol il peut avoir des salles
supplémentaires sur ce clou kate on se
rend compte que la clientèle est de plus
en plus attirés par les centres outlet
pars-lès-romilly justement par les prix
qui sont intéressantes toute l'année et
justement en sol c'est vraiment une
destination de plaisir
destination de l'achat en l'occurrence
pour une boutique de luxe c'est
l'intérêt de la aux lettres c'est que ça
rend le luxe accessible à tous avec un
taux de remplissage de près de 90% et
des boutiques éphémères le centre
commercial va accueillir cette année de
nouvelles marques
objectif séduire toujours plus de
clients ya bien évidemment des clientes
de saint quentin en yvelines on est un
peu plus large que ça nous avons nous
touchons la totalité de l'île de france
l'ensemble des départements paris nous
allons sur les départements 27-28 qui
sont à proximité des yvelines et nous
avons aussi une très jolie clientèle de
touristes en plus des périodes de soldes
et des opérations ventes privées one
nation paris misent également sur
l'événementiel sont dix jours
d'animations étaient organisées en 2017
prochain rendez-vous est les vacances
d'hiver avec les jeux olympiques qui
seront à l'honneur et pour évoquer plus
largement l'offre commerciale proposée à
saint quentin en yvelines à grégory gare
estime a rejoint sur ce plateau consorts
bonjour vous êtes vice président de
saint quentin en yvelines et délégué à
la stratégie commerciale
alors justement quelle est la stratégie
commerciale mise en place par 50 ans les
villes
allez large et vaste on a plusieurs axes
sur la stratégie commerciale que nous
conduisons maintenant depuis 2016 et
puis l'élargissement du périmètre de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
allez premièrement de maintenir un
commerce de proximité dynamique alors ça
reste de la compétence des collectivités
des communes mais l'agglomération vient
en soutien à l'est également de trouver
une lisibilité
est également d'améliorer la qualité de
l'offre commerciale sur les pôles
commerciaux dans l'agglomération et
compétente
le premier c'est plaisir les claies
ensuite on à maurepas coignières avec
paris ouest le forum du gibet et les
portes de chevreuse et ensuite on a
menti ni avec l'espace saint quentin et
skywest donc voilà ce sont des axes
importants sur lesquels nous allons
engager maintenant beaucoup d'action
alors pour enrichir cette offre
commerciale
sept projets sont prévus d'ici les
prochaines années ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus a alors on a un projet
emblématique qui sur la ville de plaisir
puisque c'est le projet open sky qui est
une requalification un renouvellement
urbain sur une zone commerciale qui
était déjà existantes un projet qu'il ya
plus de dix ans déjà et qui sort de
terre à la fin de l'année donc plus de
30 mille mètres carrés de nouvelles
surfaces commerciales 30
enseigne différente avec un leader qui
est prime marque et on a également un
autre projet qui est situé toujours sur
la ville de plaisir avec l'extension de
la galerie marchande d'auchan avec la 70
nouvelles boutiques
onze mille mètres carrés de surfaces
commerciales nouvelles d'autres projets
également sur maurepas et coignières et
la volonté également de redynamiser
skywest finalement n'y a pas trop de
centres commerciaux sur notre territoire
alors on a le double de surface
commerciale par rapport à la moyenne
française
c'est 1350 mètres carrés pour 1000
habitants alors que la moyenne c'est à
peu près 650 et on a un taux d'évasion
qui est extrêmement faible on sait bien
que les saint quentinois consomme là où
ils habitent
le taux d'évasion de 24% c'est un des
plus faibles de france ça veut dire que
en a une âme armature commerciale qui
est très importante et donc il faut
qu'on soit très vigilant dans les années
qui viennent au projet qui pourrait être
développé sur les collectivités et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut une stratégie
d'ensemble parce que si on développe
dans une ville il y aura forcément des
friches commerciales dans les autres et
donc saint quentin en yvelines doit être
vigilante vous parlais justement des
friches commerciales une taxe a été été
mis en place
justement c'est qu'elle est déjà
appliqué cette taxe justement pour
essayer de faire en sorte qu'ils aient
le moins de moins possible de locaux
vacants
oui alors on a quand même une chance sur
saint-quentin en yvelines c'est que je
lui dis on a le doubs le surface
commerciale par rapport à une française
promis pour le commercial des yvelines
on a un taux de vacance qui est quand
même très faible 6% sur la totalité
malgré tout pour les propriétaires qui
ne jouent pas le jeu et qui ne
souhaitent pas relouer leurs locaux il
existe un dispositif permis par la loi
qui est une taxe sur les friches
commerciales donc une pénalité j'allais
dire une majoration de la taxe foncière
10 % la première année qu'un sport sont
la seconde 20% à la troisième année et
il ya quelques en effet quelques
propriétaires qui sont concernés pour
les remettre autour de la table pour
comprendre pourquoi ils ne louent pas à
dérober devant un mot aussi sur
l'ouverture dominicale est ce qu'elle va
se généraliser
dans les prochaines années dans tous les
centres commerciaux de 50 ans alors
vaste sujet qui est politiquement
sensible le travail du dimanche on a
déjà par exemple les villes de dcl est
et puis de quoi nier ou ouverts le
dimanche
ce qu'on appelait à l'époque les zones
puce ce qu'on appelle maintenant les
zones commerciales et donc il est vrai
que il y à des zones commerciales qui ne
sont pas ouvertes le dimanche
et donc on a des volontés je vois pas
comment une nation qui souhaite ouvrir
tous les dimanches
donc il ya un dossier déjà qui est en
préparation en demande auprès du préfet
pour trouver une cohérence avec alpha
parc 1 et 2 qui lui c'est ensemble est
ouvert le dimanche on a une volonté
aussi de l'espace cinquantaine de
skywest d'ouvrir le dimanche
mais là on est dans une problématique
particulière parce qu'on a des
habitations qui sont situées au sud et
des magasins à l'espace saint quentin on
a une si une volonté du côté de de
maurepas des opérateurs commerciaux
donc il faut trouver une cohérence non
seulement que ça se sent seule paire en
articulation que le commerce de
proximité sûr que ça lui porte préjudice
et puis aussi de trouver de continuer à
trouver une vitalité sur l'armature
commercial du tissu commercial de saint
quentin donc leur sujet et je dois en
débattre avec mes collègues dans les
mois qui viennent
merci grigori gars essaient d'être
intervenu sur ce plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines délégué à la
stratégie commerciale tout de suite on
passe à l'acte eu économique en bref
avec les bons chiffres de l'automobile
mais aussi ce sommet sur l'attractivité
qui s'est déroulé au château de
versailles 140 grands patrons du monde
entier étaient au château de versailles
lundi 22 janvier facebook coca cola
google ou encore hsbc
ils ont répondu présent à l'invitation
du président français manuel macron un
sommet sur l'attractivité qui s'est
déroulée à huis clos
objectif inciter les grandes entreprises
à investir en france la france et plus
précisément le plateau de saclay
n'accueillera pas l'expo universelle
2025 d'importantes retombées économiques
étaient attendus pour notre région est
pourtant le premier ministre edouard
philippe a décidé de retirer la
candidature de notre pays
conséquence la construction de la ligne
18 pourrait être abandonnée selon tout
cas la présidente de région valérie
pécresse ans j'ai peur et nous avons
tous peur ici que on justifie par
l'abandon de l'exposition universelle
l'abandon de cette ligne qui est
structurante pour l'ile-de-france et
structurante pour l'économie du pays et
l'économie de notre pays booster en 2017
par les bons chiffres de l'automobile
plus 4,7 pour cent selon l'association
des constructeurs européens
à noter les très belles performances des
constructeurs français à commencer par
psa implanté dans les yvelines à poissy
et vélizy
les immatriculations du groupe affiche
une hausse de 28,1 pour cent en europe
bonne année également pour renault dont
le technocentre à guyancourt avec une
hausse de 6,7 pour cent
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi à très bientôt
[Musique]